- It's cash today?
- [Interviewer] Yes, always cash.
Cash is King.
(Black chuckles)
All right, Black Diamond,
Black diamond, where
are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Black] I grew up in Sacramento,
but I was born in Richmond, California.
- [Mark] Tell me about your family.
You had both your parents
when you were growing up?
- Oh yeah I had.
I didn't know my daddy
until I was about maybe 12.
I met my daddy on the whole stroke,
it was another gentleman that ran up on me
and say, "You look like a pimp".
I say, "I am a pimp".
I'm sitting at the bus stop,
'cause I'm just starting
out and everything.
I'm about 12 years old, got two hoes
and he said "You look like a pimp".
I say, "I'm a pimp".
He's no, "You look like a pimp,
you like this pimp named Freddy Lee".
I said, "Okay, that's my daddy name".
So he rolled up on me
introducing the quarter,
it was back in 1978, wrote
me introducing the quarter.
And he said, "Mn, your name Jeffery?"
I'm like, "Yeah".
"You see I'm your daddy".
And I said, "I know my daddy
name, what's your name?"
He said "My name Freddy Lee."
You know, I ain't know he was a pimp.
You understand me? And things like that.
And he told me a story
about my mama day night
that you know, this and that.
And you know, my mom was
a hoe, you understand?
So I knew how I got it
and where I came from.
You know?
- [Interviewer] And how
was your relationship
with him after that?
- Oh, he was a beast. (laughs)
He was a beast, man.
My daddy man, was a beast, man.
You know, it was a point where he never,
he was like cold on me.
You know, he had other
kids and things like that
from different women and things like that.
I come to find out, you understand me?
He was a player more than a pimp to me.
You know, 'cause my momma
told me a story about him too.
You know, that she made him get a job
made him stop pimping and everything.
I'm like, okay.
How a motherfucker bitch make
a motherfucker stop pimping.
You understand me?
And then he tells a story
about my mama, you know
telling my mama, your mama
manned him up, you know
mama made a motherfucker.
Let me tell you about my mama though.
At the mate, at the
mate made a motherfucker
trick by a house, across the street
from his wife.
And his wife had to ask my mama
"Can he come home to
just babysit his kids?"
You understand me?
That's that's where I come from under.
You understand? I was
born in and I sworn in it.
You know, when a motherfucker say
they born in and sworn in,
I was really born in this shit.
You understand?
My uncles, everything,
pimping coming through me.
I come out of, we started out in Fresno.
That's how I met Virgil.
You understand me?
One of the coolest
motherfucking pimps I ever knew
on this side of the Mississippi.
I don't know about the other
side of Mississippi (laughs).
But on this side of Mississippi,
he is the coldest people pimp I ever knew.
You know what I'm saying?
And so, you know, I come
up under this shit, man.
My mom was a ho, bonafide
ho you understand me?
And when she stopped hoing,
she start babysitting
for pimps and hos.
My first bitch come, you understand me?
I'm six years old.
You understand me.
Get me $5 a bed can.
And her daddy was a pimp.
Her mom was a ho.
Our Perry, you know, out of Sacramento,
you know what I'm saying?
So I come on and I'm really
raised under this shit.
So when I get really irritated
when a motherfucker say,
"Man, pimps are born hos.
You know what saying? Pimps are born".
You understand me, I
was born with a bitch.
So I wasn't born with no pimping.
You understand me?
Motherfucker say pimp born, hos are made.
I wasn't born no pimping.
If I had come out of the womb
with a twin and pimped my twin,
then I would have been
born in some pimping.
(laughs) You know what I'm saying?
So, I ain't come out
of the womb with no ho.
I had to learn this shit.
And I learned this from motherfuckers
like Bird Joe, Zack the
Mat, Hook the Crook.
You You understand me? Stiffy.
Danky, you know what I'm saying?
Gang of Richmond pimps,
you know what I'm saying?
I can mention a million motherfuckers.
You know what I'm saying?
But I mean, I get irritated.
I get irritated when
motherfuckers talk about
this pimping man.
You understand me?
'Cause pimping is when you got ho.
I ain't got a ho right
now, so I'm not pimping,
but I'm a pimp .
Is a difference.
I'm going to be a pimp till I die.
You understand me?
Bitch gonna sell a sort of
metal base through a bar,
trying to climb out trying (indistinct).
Whatever, any bitch I have.
You understand that?
I had a ho tell me one
time, you understand
"But I want to sell my pussy".
But sell what you got.
Bitch say, "I work seven jobs".
Okay, whatever you do bitch,
but when you come in my (indistinct),
had the money for show.
You understand me?
That what makes a pimp.
"Bitch put the money on my hand."
I'm not no thief.
Bitch can put the money down on a bed.
I'm not gonna take that one off the bed.
That's the bitch money
until she put it in my hand.
So motherfuckers don't
understand this game.
It's not a gain, it's a game.
We gain.
I'm not gaining on no bitch.
I'm not gonna play no
bitch, I'm not a player.
I'm not trying to play no motherfucker.
Play a bitch and make a bitch,
I'm not trying to turn nobody out.
I'm trying to turn you on. (laughs)
You know, make you fuck her for free.
You go to the club and take a man home.
Then you fucking this motherfucker,
all day going everything like that,
bitch, I don't give a
fuck about none of that.
Bitch, sell it.
Why you giving it away for free?
You know, this shit is illegal.
You understand me?
Who have not? Playboy Magazine.
One of the biggest motherfucker
players I ever knew.
You understand me?
You know?
Heidi Fleiss, that bitch was
a cold motherfucking madam.
You know what I'm saying?
When it come to pimping though,
who happened to,
had to fuck them all the way over here
and do he had to bait
them bitches or whatever.
A pimp ain't gonna give a bitch shit.
What's a pimping.
- [Interviewer] How many
girls did you have at the?
- At one time I had seven.
- Seven?
- I had seven hos.
- [Interviewer] And what was your style?
You've used force and intimidation?
- I'm a gentleman.
- [Interviewer] You're gentleman?
You understand me?
Every pimp gonna be a gentleman.
I'm not no gorilla.
I'm not obese, you understand me?
I'm not gonna force a bitch to do nothing.
You understand? I had a bitch
tell me "I'm gonna leave."
I told the bitch "Do what you need".
A taxi?
I'm gonna help the bitch leave.
I packed the clothes for the bitch.
You understand me?
It's by choice, not force.
- [Interviewer] And the
arrangement is they give you
all their money and you give them what?
- When the bitch gimme some
money, you understand me,
I got to have something.
You understand me?
I don't need no sex.
You understand the last
time I had sex, man,
you understand me?
I think I jacked off 1980 something.
You You understand me?
I'm just saying.
A bitch, when a bitch come
in to our comfort zone,
you understand me?
When she come in our comfort
zone, everything like that,
you understand me?
It's more so we just
improving what you are,
you understand your business.
You understand me?
Look, if she hungry, I'm
going to feed the bitch.
If she needs shoes, I'm
a put shoes on the bitch.
I'm a slave to the bitch.
We're slave to the ho.
A pimp is really a slave to the ho.
You understand, a bitch don't do nothing
not gonna give money.
We do everything for the bitch.
"Daddy, I'm hungry."
We going to feed the bitch.
"daddy, I'm on period".
Cotex.
Whatever we get, everything for the bitch.
The bitch don't do nothing.
She sleep and go work, that's it.
So when it comes to motherfucker saying
what we do for the bitch?
I had a bitch tell me one time,
bitch told me what a trick said.
She said, "Daddy the trick gonna say,
why he fuck with a pimp
and everything like that?
You know what I'm saying? He
don't do nothing for you."
She said, what he do,
his nothing is better than what you do.
Because everything she do,
if she crying, if she's sad,
if she going through
something, you understand?
We comfort the bitch.
We cater to the bitch.
You understand me?
That's why when back in
the day, you understand me?
They call, what's that word again?
What's that motherfucker?
(indistinct)
A (indistinct) was the man
that went got for the rich man
the trick for the bitch.
You understand me? Or whatever it is.
Just like slavery when the motherfucker
brought the bitch to the in house
when the bitch was in the
out house, whatever it was.
You understand me?
Bitch okay, going in there,
cook the best cook,
whatever it is in there
and bring basically down to my kids
or whatever it is you understand?
So we're not taking
advantage of the bitch.
The bitch is sharp.
You see a real pimp, bitch got,
they got real bottom line right now.
The bitch out there with real bottoms on.
You understand? Whatever.
Pimp you understand,
me gonna look good too.
He gonna be (indistinct) or
whatever, you understand?
A bitch glad to see a pimp
look good, you understand?
But we don't take advantage of that bitch.
That bitch was selling pussy for free.
She going to a club or whatever
it was fucking for free.
"Okay bitch, check it out.
Come on, follow me.
I'm gonna show you how to
break this motherfucker trick."
He's a trick.
Trick him, treat him, fucking
feed him, we need him.
You understand? Like trick or treat.
Smell my feet, give me
something good to eat.
You feel me?
So it's no difference.
It's no difference.
You understand?
Who a bitch that go to a
club and fucking for free.
And I seen the bitch, I said,
"Damn, you just fuck that motherfucker,
what'd you get? A drink?
That's all you got?
Bitch I'ma show you how
to get you a thousand
But can you bank in my bank?
Can I hold the money?".
Because you don't know
what to do with the money.
You understand me?
Let me hold the money.
And I guarantee.
- [Interviewer] So the girls
you had were different races?
- I'm a white ho's pimp.
I'm a white ho's pimp.
You understand me?
And that's not because in fact
I don't love my black women
or whatever it is.
But I'm not going to pimp my black women.
Is something against
me. You understand me?
Because my family was like Black Panthers
or whatever like that.
So I'm not gonna take them
to a level you understand me,
and fuck them up.
You feel me?
- [Interviewer] And you
have sex with girls or no?
- I ain't never, I ain't
got no baby by no bitch.
Not no ho. (laughs)
I ain't got no kids.
I'm a virgin. (laughs)
I'm really a virgin.
You understand me?
I get my nuts off and
everything like that,
it's got to be a square bitch.
And that's very rare.
I'm not gonna give no ho my baby
and this bitch fucking with another pimp.
You understand me?
And then I got to go tell him,
"Can I see my baby?"
Or whatever it is you understand me?
And he feeding my baby
bad or whatever like that.
So I'm not gonna even go that route.
So when I,
I don't understand how a pimp
stick their dick in a bitch.
They ain't going to me.
They don't mean no pimping to me.
Motherfucker got a baby by hos.
I ain't never seen motherfucker pimps got
baby by hos when I was coming up.
You understand me?
Unless they then married the bitch.
That's that whole had been there
for 10, 15, 20 years or whatever.
That's a down bitch.
They talking about bottom bitch.
A bottom bitch gotta be a
bitch that you understand,
went to penitentiary or everything
when she young.
Or kill a motherfucker will raise a hand.
"You talk to me, I kill cut
your throat" or whatever.
They make bottom bitches in six months.
I be a bottom bitch and
a bitch ain't show you
she's a bottom bitch.
The bottom bitch is a
bitch I can stand on.
That's what you call bottom bitch to me.
Bitch I can stand on you.
You my motherfucking foundation.
I'm not gonna sink fucking with you.
That means you's a bottom bitch.
- [Interviewer] What's most
important to you in life?
- God.
God.
God is the most important thing to me.
That's my hangup.
That's my hangup to the point where
that what made me take retirement parties.
Because I want to, you understand me,
when I die, I want to go to heaven.
I believe in that.
And so I know I can't
go to heaven pimping.
You understand me, it's pimp or die.
No, not with me, not with me.
I'm not going to pimping before God.
You understand me?
And so that makes me take vacations
and question my lifestyle or
whatever it is you understand?
Because in fact, I want to go to heaven.
It's something that I believe in.
And so I knowing that pimping is a sin.
Sin is a woman is a sin.
That's something that my flesh is doing.
You understand?
This is a fleshly thing,
you understand me?
But it's not what my
spirit should be doing.
And so that's tug of war with me.
Just like when Saul
said, you understand me,
is a war in my spirit.
You understand? Things that
I want to do, I don't do.
Things I do do, I don't do.
Do you understand me?
So that's the war with me.
If it went no such thing as God,
or if I die, I just die and I go to sleep
and never wake up again,
I'll pimp and ain't give a fuck.
I'd have kill a gang of motherfuckers.
You understand me?
But I know I don't want that damage on me.
I got to live some kind of
way where God could say,
"Hey, I got some, come back."
And that's the war against me.
I don't know about other
pimps or other people
or whoever, but that's the war with me.
I want to go to heaven, you know?
And I can't pimp and die and go to heaven.
- [Interviewer] What
personality trait do you possess
that helps you to do this?
- I'm a people person.
I'm a people person.
I don't care what walk of
life, you understand me?
And I bless so many.
You understand me?
Pimp that see this footage,
you don't say this diamond.
You know, he didn't bless me.
You know what I'm saying? I won't lie.
I tell the truth. I'm the proof.
You You understand me?
I guess I'm molding see
all these homies I had,
about what I have, I got $10 in my pocket
and motherfucker saying,
"Man, I need that 10.
Just get me a hit."
I give it to him.
'Cause I can go home and I'm cool.
I'm a people person.
I get along with all walk of life.
I don't judge no one.
And when it comes to that point
when you don't judge no one,
you understand me, you win.
You understand me?
The Bible say you understand,
"Blessed is a cheerful giver,
for his shall inherit the earth."
So the earth is my turf (laughs).
You know what I'm saying.
I'm blessed with no stress.
- [Interviewer] What do you
think the core of a pimp
and prostitute relationship is?
Are the girls looking for a
replacement of their father?
- Well, when it come to a woman,
you say girl, I don't fuck with girls.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, woman sorry.
- Okay, say woman, you understand?
When it come to a woman,
it could be that she's-
- [Interviewer] I didn't
say ditch. (laughs)
- No, you said girl.
- I know.
- Keep girl out of footage.
- [Interviewer] I used the wrong term,
but it could've been worse.
- Yeah, but girl,
girl mean somebody young.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You understand understand me?
So you can't put that with pimping.
You understand me? 'Cause
when it comes to a girl,
I kill a motherfucker that sent a girl.
Anything under 18 needs to be dead.
You understand what I'm saying?
So don't use that.
But we not no motherfucker pedophiles.
You You understand me?
So a motherfucker going
to jail for pedophiling
and fucking with a young bitch.
Yeah, he need to be getting killed
when he go to penitentiary.
Fucking turning man.
You turn my daughter up and she young,
I kill you.
Once she 18? She grown.
I can't do nothing.
- [Interviewer] But the
relationship between a woman
and her pimp-
- Yeah, when it comes to that
when it comes to that,
it comes to.
I can put it this way.
I can see a young lady walking up
and I could see her head down.
I can read her spirit.
You understand me?
She's down.
She's moping about something.
And she looking for answer
and she looking for a clue.
So when I walk to her,
"Hey, how you doing darling?
Why you got a frown on your face?
Oh you know, my daddy did
this, my boyfriend did this
(mumbles)".
Okay well, man you don't understand me
that happened there.
You understand me?
And then you got to uplift her.
When you uplift her, you understand me?
When you uplift that individual,
and you're giving the answer,
you answer all the questions in her head.
She will do anything for you
because something like that
is what she's been looking
and seeking and searching
and trying to find.
A answer.
And when you can answer the questions
in her head.
Give a fuck if she's a nun (laughs)
you're the one.
Look at Charles Mason, he
had bitch killing for him
because he answered the
questions in their head.
What they was going through.
Look at Jim Jones.
You know what I'm saying?
Asking the questions in their head.
Look at the preachers, the
pastors, whatever is going on.
Answer the questions.
If somebody answer the
questions in your head.
Right now I can tell you how
to make this footage better.
You gonna get me on the pay line.
That's how it is.
The coolest pimp was Lucifer.
He made Eve make Adam a snitch.
What did Adam say when
God came to the garden
and say where are you at, Adam?
He say I'm hiding.
"Why are you hiding?" "I'm naked".
"who told you you was naked?"
"This bitch you gave
me" you understand me?
You feel me?
Bitch what you do?
The snake came through,
walking through the garden.
"Hey bitch, where's Adam?
Where's Adam?
Why you don't bite from
that tree and everything?
You understand me?
Ah, she gotta die, but you
ain't gonna die right now.
You might die later but you
Adam was his trick.
Eve was the first ho.
You understand me?
And the snake was the
current first pimp, Lucifer.
Just want to go back and do.
That's why pimping ho, I've been through
the motherfucking bible.
You understand me?
David sent the motherfucker
to the front line
for the wife, whatever it is.
I could tell you stories.
I'm wanting glory.
You know what I mean?
I'm deep with this shit, man.
I'm really invested in pimping.
Motherfucker go to college, go to college.
I know everything, the
depths of this shit.
Motherfuckers ain't sold in, sold out.
A lot of motherfuckers today
as you were saying earlier.
A lot of motherfuckers today is pimping
because the dope game got slow.
So they're thugs, wearing jeans,
wearing this and that.
But pimps are gentlemen.
Look at Virgil, he's a gentleman.
Zack and Mat, a gentleman.
(indistinct) Slim, a gentleman.
You understand me, Gangster
Brown, a gentleman.
(indistinct) a gentleman.
Stiffy, a gentlemen.
Hook the Crook, a gentleman.
Stiffy, a gentleman.
Danky, a gentleman.
Talking about gentlemen.
Gentlemens, you understand me?
You know, I just want to fuck with.
Gentleman's.
And we are never, we never
take it out of character
whatever it is.
You understand me?
Peputy Pew, gentleman.
You know, giants.
David Falk, gentleman.
Honey Dripper, gentleman.
I don't want to mention so
many motherfuckers, man.
I really don't.
And I want you to keep all
that footage that I just said.
It's gentleman's, so I'm a gentleman.
So I'm not gonna make no bitch.
I don't need you, let
the welfare feed you.
I let him sucky grease in you.
But you fuck with me,
invest in his pimping,
and we're gonna get rich.
But I'm not going to hide.
I'm a divided it.
I'm gonna share it on my bed.
You understand me?
Bitch, whatever you need,
I guarantee you, you will
never want for nothing again.
(man laughs)
Never again.
- [Interviewer] Are drugs a
part of the picture for you?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Are drugs a
part of the picture for you?
- Say it again.
- [Interviewer] Drgs. Do you take drugs?
- Do I take drugs?
- Yes.
- Oh no.
No, I did drugs.
- Yeah.
- Don't get it twisted. I
mean, I don't know a pimp alive
that never did no drugs.
But I do know pimp that ain't no do drugs.
Zack the Mat ain't doing,
Virgin ain't no do no.
You don't understand me.
I did some, you understand me?
But we don't pimp with drugs.
I'm not gonna give a bitch no drugs.
You understand me?
I don't pimp like, a bitch ask me,
"Can I get some drugs
then I pimp for you?"
Bitch, I'm not gonna fuck
with no drug addict bitch.
Not me. You understand me?
- [Interviewer] Is stealing
from a John's part of the game?
- No, that is not a game.
And why you got to steal from the John?
- [Interviewer] I hear a lot of stories
of that kind of stuff.
- I'll beat the bitch up,
take something for the John.
- Okay.
- You understand me?
I mean, you ain't gotta
steal from the John.
Play him.
I mean the bitch playing
for 20,000, 40,000,
ain't got jewelry or whatever like that.
He slip.
But to steal?
No, is a difference from
stealing and playing.
'Cause he slept.
You understand me?
As the motherfucker, you understand me had
a gang motherfucking jewelry on a dresser
in front of a ho, and he slept.
The bitch would bring
all that to me. (laughs)
I need it.
But the bitch ain't gonna go look.
He's sleeping and the
bitch ain't going to look
on his dresser and all that for shit.
She gonna take money and come on leaving.
But when she could play him out of it,
oh yeah, then she gonna get it.
Based on ho no steal nothing.
I ain't never seen a ho steal shit.
A ho stealing is like
taking, you understand me?
When it comes to a ho,
'cause that John left the
jewelry on the dresser,
his Rolex and everything like that,
oh that bitch gonna pick it up.
- [Interviewer] All right.
Thank you so much for talking with me.
Thanks for coming down.
- Oh yeah.